this is Jim
he's cleaning the reflecting pools at
the 911 Memorial in New York City
Jim and his team are working beneath a
27 foot tall waterfall in near total
darkness vacuuming every inch of the
pool their goal is to do it without
missing a spot
it's a physically demanding job but
that's not the only challenge
I've never actually marked how many
miles it is but you do a few miles in
there and it could be humid and you come
out of there and you feel like you've
walked on the moon almost
the pools are nearly an acre each so it
would take hours to finish the job
before the sun comes up
while he works inside the pool other
crew members work on the bronze panels
above ground
these routines happen five days a week
and are essential for keeping the
memorial in pristine condition for the
millions who come to pay their respects
here
they start by shutting off the
waterfalls and over the next eight hours
Jim and his team work tirelessly to deep
clean this pool
the hardest part is it's it's a long
test the pool is Big it's not a uh a
swimming pool you know it's a 200 by 200
Giant pool
I'm going to pull the hose out and then
bring it back
just you don't have to use the whole
reel we got too much hose
we usually have three men through the
pool so two guys be in the pool and one
guy will be outside running the the
pumps which collect the debris and
return the clean water back to the pool
once we're set we're on our way I go and
vacuum generally and I have whoever's
with me that night brushes behind come
on hurry up
I'm gonna look out all day yeah
all right the vacuum will capture most
of the debris and the person brushing
will knock up some of the other loose
debris that doesn't get caught and it
will be caught into like some of our
filters that we have running downstairs
no I'm trapped in the hose here
I'm gonna trip myself
a little bit on America's Loopers
the workers generally clean out dirt
leaves and algae from the bottom of the
pools they also remove larger items that
visitors drop or throw in they don't
always know what they'll encounter in
the pool each night
we find kids toys little small items
depends on the crowd one night I
actually found a bat in there and I'm
not talking about a baseball bat I'm
talking about a bat who was pretty wild
when it flew away from me when when I
realized I was grabbing a bat
depending on the cleanliness of the pool
it could take anywhere between
six and seven hours and sometimes if we
feel up to it we could do it a little
quicker
some people treat this place like a
wishing well so we do catch some money
and unfortunately I think some people
being that it's so far removed from the
original 911 I think some people are a
little uneducated about this place and
some people treat it like just a regular
Fountain and they're throwing garbage in
here sometimes too you know people have
to learn that this isn't your uh Mall
fountain
I knew a few of the Brokers that passed
away
a whole uh a whole group of them
had a meeting in one of the towers
unfortunately and uh
except for one one Trader
all of them perished
I I think about them often
because we go up top where the names are
and brush near the name plates the
troughs and uh on the North side they
were all all on one panel
so I see I see the names just about
every day
total waste of lives that you know could
have been doing good good in the world
now
while Jim and the team finished cleaning
the pools below Ryan is tackling the
bronze name panels above
the panels honor the
2983 victims of the attacks on the World
Trade Center both in 1993 and 2001.
Ryan will have to strip the top layer of
metal and use a blow torch to remove a
carving someone etched onto the plaque
without damaging the rest of the
memorial
this confuses me why you'd want to write
something here
[Music]
for a mark like that you have to go
pretty deep get all the way down
otherwise you can't really get rid of it
if you don't go down far enough you'll
see it when you refinish it the further
down you go the better sometimes I've
seen nice things written but you know
they don't understand you just you can't
just write whatever you want on it
after briefly assessing the damage Ryan
needs to remove the protective bars so
he can reach the entire metal surface
to do this he props up the bars with a
wood Plank and unhooks the brackets
holding up the panels
is uh rub it down with the NAFTA it's
almost like a paint thinner it just kind
of takes the wax off so I'm not burning
wax
and it shouldn't take too long once I
get the torch on it
there's so much in the prep and then the
finishing the torch is actually
not that bad
after sanding down the top layer of
panel and neutralizing the wax Ryan is
ready to blowtorch the damaged area to
melt the metal in the patina so he can
repaint the color layer and restore the
panel to its original state
this is what we use
and it's basically just
a patina in a solution
ah I haven't used you in a while
prep them
so I'm basically getting up to the right
temperature if it's too cold it'll go on
spotty if it's too hot it'll kind of
evaporate off or it'll get burnt
the summer months the longest part of
the job is waiting for the burned panel
to cool before applying a new layer of
wax and an acrylic top coat to finish
the restoration process
we're gonna put the acrylic spray on it
it's just kind of like a clear coat
helps it kind of adhere a little bit
better
the last step really well besides
buffing the wax off so I'm just going to
put the wax on real nice not too hard
not a lot you don't need a ton
just put it on lightly
the wax will go over the finish and make
it look once I polish it
it will look brand new
got a little bit of heat but that's
because it's still hot
but it was right here
now all Ryan has to do is buff off the
excess wax using a white Scotch Brite
pad and then once it gets smooth you
know you're done
when people do something like that I
wouldn't say it makes me angry
I get it some of these people might not
have even been alive when it happened or
they were too young to get it my uncle
was a New York City firefighter and he
was hurt really bad here but luckily he
survived we got we got a little lucky
after a strenuous six to seven hours of
cleaning Jim and the team are ready to
head out of the pool
by tomorrow morning a new batch of
visitors will see sparkling pools below
rushing waterfalls and most of them
won't know that Jim's team was even here
when we finished the pool most of the
time we just we're just ready to really
get out of there and most of our
inspection you know we're fairly
confident that we did the proper job
there's always a little fail Factor but
you know not too bad
my father worked in these buildings
almost his whole life
and my father was here for uh the 93
bombing and that was before cell phones
and everything and he was the he was on
the 30th floor of the second tower when
he was there he was like the floor
Marshall he came home full of soot but
he stayed there because there was people
that couldn't get down the steps so we
made sure that he stayed with them
so I think on 9 11 day you know if he
was here
we probably would have lost them because
he wouldn't have left
he passed away a couple of years ago
he was always so proud of the job I I
probably had chances to do other things
in this building but even if I wanted to
do another job
I wouldn't because of him and I and now
you know I I love doing it so I do it